un Rover qui circule non pas sur Mars
mais sur la terre de Beauce le robot à 4
roues motrices et dans sa dernière phase
d'expérimentation son système des
farouchements des corbeaux est déjà au
point et la rampe de pulvérisation est
en passe de l'être
l'ajout d'une caméra va permettre
vraiment avec des retours en immersion
et les caméras des lunettes d'immersion
va permettre de détecter les mauvaises
herbes et de diminuer et la consommation
d'herbicides l'inventeur a pensé son
robot pour qu'il fonctionne de façon
totalement autonome
on lui dit voilà il y a telle surface à
faire tu passes tous les 10 mètres en là
tu fais des grandes longueurs de 10
mètres et voilà vous le lancez et après
il part tout seul et il nous appelle
quand il a fini parmi la panoplie
d'outils conçus par le céréalier la
palme revient au trichodrop un
distributeur automatique de petites
billes blanches remplies d'auxiliaire
très friand de la pyrale du maïs
un truc connexion électrique cette
petite mouche vient pondre dans les œufs
des pyrales pour pouvoir les pour
pouvoir les tuer entre guillemets avant
on le faisait à la main c'était trois
pages je lance à gauche trois pages je
lance à droite trois pages de position
et c'est vrai que là ça sera beaucoup
plus précis et surtout moins fatiguant
pour nous Rémi gager travaille au
développement de son robot en
collaboration avec la greentech Valley à
Orléans un incubateur des technologies
numériques qui visent à réduire l'impact
de l'agriculture sur l'environnement on
essaye de mettre le minimum possible
pour produire le plus possible donc
c'est vraiment l'enjeu et puis aussi par
rapport à l'attractivité des métiers
aussi la pénibilité en agriculture comme
beaucoup de secteurs d'activités on
connaît des problèmes de recrutement et
donc les solutions robotiques aussi
parfois viennent compenser les problèmes
voilà de main d'oeuvre dans les filières
agricoles prochaine étape
l'industrialisation du rover avec un
prix annoncé à moins de 20.000 euros